You know, one of the traps that I will sometimes
fall into, and I know that that many of my
friends do as well, and people I follow on
Twitter is this idea that, OK, this is over
the line, no one is actually going to find
a way to defend this.
And every single time we are disappointed
or is it surprised or let down or whatever
the case may be. And this applies to the insurrectionist
mob of rioters that Donald Trump incited yesterday
who went to the U.S. Capitol, breached security,
breached the doors, broke windows, got into
Nancy Pelosi's office and vandalized and so
on and so forth. And I I sort of jokingly,
what's a joke these days? I sort of tongue
in cheek suggested I'm sure they'll figure
out a way to blame and defend Black Lives
Matter for this. And that's exactly what many
people did. Here is a clip from. So this is
happening at the high level and it's happening
at the low level for a clip at the high level
when last night the vote resumed in the joint
session. Most networks were covering it, but
on Fox News, Laura Ingraham was saying that
she heard that from The Washington Times.
There were at least two antifa spotted in
the crowd. I'm not kidding.
Take a look at actions we saw today do not
represent this movement. The Washington Times
is reporting that at least two antifa were
spotted in the crowd.
So, listen, first of all, even if it were
true that there were two antifa spotted, there
were thousands of violent Trump insurrectionists
pushing their way onto the Capitol Portico
and some of them into the building, et cetera,
et cetera. So even if it were true that 24
were spotted, it wouldn't really tell us much
about the reality of what took place yesterday.
It was a incited by Trump, pro Trump, Trump's
riotous, seditious insurrection period. But
what does it mean to antifa were spotted?
Did they have signs? Because if they were
just dressed in black, a lot of the riot is
pro. Trump Seditionists were also dressed
in black and they specifically, many of them
planned to dress in black. So what if this
is true? It's irrelevant. Whether it's true
is a real question. And then, of course, the
idea that this is anything other than a genuine
pro Trump movement is not supported by fact
now, unfortunately. So Ingram is an example
of this happening at the high level.
Oh, it's too antifa were spotted in absolute
trash. OK, but friends of mine who have conservative
family members, as an example, I had an inbox
full of screenshots and and posts yesterday
of my friends on my friends, cousin, whoever
else posting all sorts of content, claiming
that this entire thing was staged by the left.
There really weren't any trumpet's, that the
trumpets that were there and peacefully walked
to the Capitol weren't the same ones that
breached. And of course, you have to suspend
all disbelief in order to to even plausibly
consider that this is the case. But unfortunately,
once again, when we assume wrongly this is
over the line, nobody will defend this. Even
for them, this is too much. We're wrong every
single time.
And they've figured out a way through a combination
of arguing that a few bad apples, maybe not
even right wingers, they are the bad apples,
might all have been antifa are black lives
matter for which there is no evidence. Another
version that I saw and in fact there are some
enlightened centrists who have YouTube channels
who were making this case. The problem is
the media with bloodlust showing the video
of what's going on. I actually heard that
yesterday and saw it on Twitter today, which
is the problem is not the first order, which
is that people are doing this and they are
trumpet's. And even though we were told it's
the left that's violent, it's the right that
has done something that hasn't happened since
the 19th century, breaching the Capitol building
with with property crime and vandalism and
violence and all the stuff that's really the
issue.
There were people saying that the media's
coverage of this is sensational and salacious.
What what that's that's what you think is
the problem, the fact that media were accurately
reporting about the seditious insurrectionist,
riotous behavior that was taking place. So
we've seen every combination. There is no
defense to absurd. There is no defense to
ridiculous that some of them won't try it.
You know, there's all these rules, Godwin's
Law, which I think is the longer an Internet
discussion goes on, the more likely it becomes
someone makes an analogy to Hitler or Nazis
or, you know, all all of the Occam's razor.
Or there should be some principle named for
the idea that any defense of Trump or Trump
ists, no matter how absurd, will eventually
be made and put out there by by some of these
Trump ists. And all we can really do is continue
to stick to the facts, not become overly.
You know, one of the things was a lot of people
were writing to me saying, how do I respond
to this? You know, my aunt is posting that
what's going on is not really what's going
on. What what do I do? And my my advice is
do nothing. Unfortunately, my I think that
if you want to adopt what I call a retail
strategy, which is arguing with people one
on one, I don't really have advice for you.
I really don't I don't think it's a good idea.
If some if somebody really sees what happened
yesterday and actually believes or has convinced
themselves that they believe it was really
antifa or something like that, I don't see
the point of arguing with them. I think the
healthier approach is to say this person believes
this stuff as a result of like a 40 year campaign
of pseudo and anti intellectualism and false
talking points that really go back to like
Reagan's idea of this welfare queen who was
just getting rich off of having kids and drove
a Cadillac and and live this great life. That
is sort of the beginning of everything we've
seen. Immigrants are these are dangerous and
communists are coming in and social. Joe Biden,
the social you know, all that stuff. We need
to be thinking about more of a wholesale strategy,
which includes changing the media landscape,
changing the culture, changing education.
And my instinct is that's healthier than getting
frustrated with Aunt Blanche sharing that
crazy thing about how it was really antifa
who did the thing. To me, it seems like an
exercise in futility, but I'm open to having
my mind changed that. That's just my advice